I wouldn't pay uh ten thousand dollars
to get re-circumcised
three
I'm circumcised but I mean like they're
like we could replace the hymen I would
get circumcised and then recircumcised
re you mean like cut more yeah
[Music]
all right guys check this out high five
um we got a 22 year old beautiful
Brazilian woman here
[Laughter]
things like that the pants I mean hello
is that a Nicki Minaj look she's that's
a Nicki Minaj look it's more of like a
Kardashian objectively attractive woman
yeah even at the fear of you later on
saying that this is a dude I'm still
alive I'm still alive she's fine it's
not a trap at all high cheekbones
they're contoured
she's
definitely not she's a real 22 year old
Brazilian woman she's a murderer no
she's a good woman but
she has ugly feet
the actual thing is is that there
seemingly isn't anything wrong with her
but she's paying 10 000 to get one more
cosmetic surgery adjustment done what do
you think that is smaller dick let it
see it let's see it again see it again
ten thousand dollars ten thousand bucks
ten thousand ten thousand I don't know
if she's had previous surgery at all I'm
just saying she's about to pay 10K to
get this thing done robotic arm do you
know how uh what like this this is how I
would diagnose it
a lot of the prettiest chicks have
lowest self-esteem and insecurity what
is this this is my this is my [__]
Magneto helmetizers
what does she think her insecurity is
okay that's a good way you know what I
mean let me give you a hint coming up
with something totally
not I know first thing you would think
exactly because those chicks are dumb
[__] dumbass chicks always do [__]
like that [__] vagina
[Music]
that's the only thing you can think of
but very close but it is along that she
wants to close all holes because she
doesn't want to [__] or poop no because
I poop RP ever again because girls don't
do that oh she wants to trim her libyas
because she got thick labias she got her
ladies are fine okay okay she wants to
bleach it wait can you surgically make
your vagina tighter is that what you
said I think she wants to bleach her
vagina maybe it's kind of like the same
the right color for ten thousand dollars
in the surgery you could bleach your
butthole oh you know what maybe she's
trying to uh reshape it
so instead of up and down it's a
horizontal
she wants a horizontal [__] it's cost
her 10K the lips yeah
90 degree adjustment hot dogs and
hamburgers 90 degrees hot dog to
Hamburger classic surgery
I love it can you fold your paper in Hot
Dogs is it hot dog yeah exactly dude she
wants a burger the King Burger King
she's gonna pay 10K to get her hymen
restored oh that's yeah that's [__]
love wasting money
give me more information see this is
this is this is the amazing duality of
it right guys are [__] dumb dogs
that's why only fans chicks are [__]
bowling all kinds of money but on the
flip side
guys can also go most beautiful woman in
the world I know what you're insecure
about give me 10 G's and then the hot
chicks are like okay take all my money I
knew I wasn't as fine as I thought I was
that's true it's like the Sims are
paying the the only fans girl the only
fans girls paying the plastic surgeon
and the plastic surgeons [__] paid
his mistress the mistress that's the
economy okay you [__] chimpanzees all
it really is is that she knows she's
fine and she has this vision of herself
where she wants to look like even finer
by having a hymen yeah
that was the case
if that was the case she would go to med
school why would she go to med school
because when dudes go oh I know what I
want to do with my car they work on
their car right they go she can work on
her [__] she can be like scalpel
exactly there you goes the med school
no one with the stiff neck okay does
like does is there something about like
restoring your hymen that makes you feel
virgin you got to be you got it as
someone who who bled the first time it's
not it's just it's inconvenient I don't
know what it is why would you want to
get a spider web put in there so she
could tear maybe maybe the person who
tear it from her turret it the wrong way
and like it was a bad experience [__]
riding a horse or in an accident oh no
you set us up Ryan what you [__] said
I didn't set you up tell us the reason
no I know how detox feels
find the video with that inside joke all
right so the reason she wants to get her
home oh no something bad she never had
one in the first place because
when she was 17 yeah okay give it to us
today just give it to a straight dude we
know what the answer is ready just tell
him son of a [__] when she was 17 she
was uh taken advantage of by some 30
year old dude that's what I said that's
why it's like it was taken from her the
wrong way who took her virginity and and
gave made all these promises that he was
gonna stay with her and like kind of
like manipulated mine and then and then
just bounced after having sex with her
so she's revirginizing herself
re-virginize yourself that's what I'm
saying
that's the insecurity of it that's not
an insecurity yes that is no it's not
that's literally the definition of
insecurity she was taken advantage of I
gotta go against him fight him fight him
do it all the MMA fighters right they go
how come you're so good at fighting
because when I was five some guy beat me
up every MMA fighter is like that yeah
let her have what she wants every
bodybuilder what do you put on those
muscles when I was five to beat me up
that's true
okay I can't wait to hear Jesus every
[__] Macho sport you go you ask them
why it's insecurity okay but the way he
presented it in the beginning was that
these guys are picking out these [__]
insecurities in us and that's why we go
oh yeah you're right I am Lester then
let me fix them the voices are great
right but that's not what happened here
she's taking her power back right where
she feels like something was taken from
her that she didn't want taken from her
so she's like you know what I don't need
an outside I think to to like make me
feel better I'm gonna do this for me you
don't got to spend 10 G's then it's I
don't know how she's gonna do it
remember at the beginning of the day
when they're like we don't bump heads
yeah yeah this is good no this is good
we're gonna have some good sex after
some hymens will be rebroken rebroken
take advantage of those insecurements
take it it just sounds like she doesn't
want to take responsibility for dating
the wrong guy well no she she takes she
said she this is her quote she said I
always wanted to have that special
moment I wanted to be unique and
romantic like in fairy tales that's why
I'm having surgery she wants to just do
it again but the right way that's all
because she's like oh I got caught with
a player yeah and then he was like
making all these promises he duped me
she got got and then I lost my virginity
there's also the fact that you know
maybe to to us we're like ten thousand
dollars do that like that's ridiculous
but maybe ten thousand of hers like five
bucks yeah you poor bastards you [__]
peasants that's true because I wouldn't
pay uh ten thousand dollars to get
re-circumcised
three
I'm circumcised by me like they're like
we could replace a Hyman I would get
circumcised and then re-circumcised read
you mean like cut more yeah
re-trip the doctors
the doctor's like hell yeah I'm gonna
make I'm making it like I'm making five
rounds of money on this guy sir you have
the foreskin left cut it deeper
stretch it cut it again
what is this what is this I feel it why
can't I pull sir
there's too much slack on this thing I
feel like a hairless chihuahua come on
is she um is she like an influencer or
anything like that I could see a small
subconscious or conscious part of it
also just being like a thing to do
because it's something to talk about
well and it's also genius marketing
because she can be saying she's gonna do
this I'm a virgin now she well she
doesn't even have to follow through with
it true who's gonna [__] say she got
it for real who gives the [__] [__]
post the receipts on her stories yeah
now all the Sims that are just like man
I just want to de-virginize her now
because she you can it does increase her
value though if she's then I want to
save her because the way the way it went
down why she's doing the intention is so
like yeah so she's creating way more
Sims AKA customers I mean good for her
good
first the genius because all I know is
that those that
that material is going viral for
leggings but she has a whole bodysuit
and now she's gonna sell me that I wait
okay that was a very covered Tick-Tock
viral leggings that women were wearing
all the time
that's all I'm saying that's true
you're not following the type of women
I'm following that's why you don't know
he's right there wasn't a bodysuit it
were definitely leggings that would make
your ass look beautiful it was a trend
of oh I got those Tick Tock wedding I
thought the tick tock wedding so I get
my husband to react to it yep and now
she's fine though get it curves I don't
even know you can get her a hymen
replaced you can even get one added that
like a double hymen yeah brother you can
change your whole gender all right but a
hymen though I feel like that's like I
don't even know that was a thing you can
get a whole [__] brand new heart
you can also break your hymen not
sexually at all like just doing
activities are people saying like riding
horses sometimes that happen yeah I
literally said all of that did you I'm
not even here
was it this video probably break your
[__] a dildo too
that's very true
I'm in facts
[Music]